Speaker 1: All right, let's get into the mailbag
for the week, the mailbag continues to be
increasingly popular both for people who have
something constructive and substantive to
share.
And people who have nothing of value to share
other than insults, slurs and the like.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
If you have a message for us that maybe would
be interesting to discuss during the mailbag.
Let's start today with the email.
You're a bully paid for by George Soros and
Alex Soros.
Now, I have to admit I have never heard the
name Alex Soros before suggesting that shows
hosted by Jewish people are paid for by Jewish
person George Soros is a very well-established
anti-Semitic trope.
We have been targeted by it for a very long
time.
I have never been accused of being paid by
Alex Soros and I don't know who that is.
Presumably the son of George Soros.
I don't know.
Sounds interesting.
I wonder what he's up to.
And of course, you're a bully.
Who am I?
Bullying would be the question I have that
is not also not an allegation.
I have ever faced Lanzarote in asking about
our Facebook situation, saying, David, I watched
your show about a week ago where you talked
about Facebook, the monetizing your content
for 90 days over essentially reporting the
news.
This got my ire up and I contacted a friend
that works for Facebook who looked into it
further.
Here is the official reply.
Thank you for bringing this to our attention.
We've reviewed the content you reported and
found it doesn't violate community standards.
We apologize for the mistake here and have
restored your content and taken steps to ensure
it doesn't happen again.
And Lance wants to know what happened.
Yes, I am now able to announce that thanks
to you about 10 of you actually, we have a
ton of Facebook employees in our audience.
It turns out your friends and family of Facebook
employees.
Thanks to all of you guys, we have been re
Monitise re monetized on Facebook.
A bunch of people wrote in saying This is
not anti-vaccine content.
The David Pakman Show is not anti-vax.
This is some kind of false algorithmic thing,
and we learned that indeed, no real person
flagged our account.
Something about our post could have been the
thumbnail, which included Alex Jones could
have been the text.
We don't know Goddess demonetized and it was
incorrect.
And so a whole bunch of you guys who work
at Facebook submitted internal appeals.
It took about 15 days or so, set 16 days,
something like that.
But we are re monetized on Facebook and I
have only you guys to thank, so I really appreciate
that.
Let's continue with the mailbag, Mike wrote
in and is not pleased with me.
Mike says David, I noticed that on the January
19th show you mentioned how to get at home
COVID tests would be in the bonus show.
I'm sure you didn't intend this, but putting
that content behind a paywall could be viewed
as tacky or underhanded way of encouraging
subscriptions.
The information is not secret.
It's why it's just COVID tests dot gov.
Every day this one is frustrating.
Every day I just tell people what's on the
bonus show.
And so that day it was like, we're going to
talk about the new program to get free COVID
tests.
We're going to talk about this.
We're going to talk about that.
You can just Google free COVID test is the
first thing that comes up, but the information
is not secret in any way.
I was not encouraging subscriptions with the
idea that I would tell you where to get free
COVID tests if you get a membership.
A little frustrating because I mean, it's
a Biden plan.
It was all over the news.
It's COVID tests.
Dot gov.
But OK, it is what it is.
Bill Rhoden about the January 6th Committee
and says, Hi David.
Sir, is there.
There is one thing that I would that would
greatly impact voters and voting in 2022 or
2024.
If the committee shows somehow that Trump
had nothing to do with what happened on January
6th, I know it's unlikely, but Stranger Things
have happened.
Think 2016?
That's a really good point.
So what?
What is this about last week?
I said I want the Jan. six committee to finish
its work before the November elections, why
if Republicans win in November, as soon as
they're sworn in in January, they're ending
the committee.
So I would like the committee to actually
finish its work.
Without being forcibly shut down, even though
I know that no matter what the committee says,
the committee could say Trump was the one
guy who planned the insurrection or whatever,
and it would not change the minds of voters.
In other words, I don't think the results
of that committee will make a difference.
Bill has a good point, which is if the results
were Trump is completely innocent and has
no blame whatsoever.
No one around Trump has any blame for the
insurrection that actually might impact 2024,
and it would be similar sort of to that last
minute James Comey press conference.
Remember, for all the talk of James Comey
being so hostile to Trump and friendly to
Hillary.
James Comey choosing to do that second press
conference about the Hillary email investigation
so close to the 2016 election absolutely played
a role.
To some degree, we can't say it was a decisive
role, but it played a role in the ultimate
outcome.
So I don't think that's going to happen, Bill.
I agree with you.
But if it did, if that if the results were,
we finished our investigation and Trump did
nothing wrong and neither did anybody around
him, that actually would be a factor.
I don't expect that that's going to happen.
Haley wrote in about Carhartt this.
I like this story.
Are conservatives on car?
Hart's news revealing their vaccine mandate
are big, mad and making my night?
We definitely should be supporting their business.
Just the most recent Facebook post on their
page has the right acting like snowflakes.
I love this story, so a lot of people I think
don't know about the brand Carhartt.
Now I'm going to try to accurately describe
it.
Carhartt is a brand that sells a lot of sort
of like working gear, particularly for the
cold or at least growing up in Massachusetts.
I would always see people on construction
site would have Carhartt pants, fleece lined
Carhartt jackets, and there was this association
with Carhartt as being a conservative brand,
rightly or wrongly.
And it may have been because it became popular
with sort sort of folks who see it as emblematic
of rugged individualism and being out doing
work, you know, chainsaws and whatever.
Anyway, you guys get the point.
And growing up there was always like nearby.
I went to the like the regular high school
and there was an alternative vocational high
school.
And the Vocational High School was significantly
more conservative in its makeup.
And there were a lot of Carhartt stuff around.
So I think there's the Association of Carhartt
as a conservative brand that may not even
be accurate.
Turns out, Carhartt requires their employees
to be vaccinated, and it has gone crazy with
conservatives saying We will now boycott Carhartt.
I saw videos of people burning Carhartt clothes
and all of this different stuff.
I absolutely love it.
I don't know if there is an alternative to
Carhartt.
Is L.L.
Bean really an alternative?
It doesn't seem like, I don't know.
I don't know much about Carhartt as a brand,
but I am loving the instant triggering that
we are seeing from these people because they're
beloved, Carhart says.
Hey, for safety, you've got to be vaccinated
to work here.
Dustin wrote in Dustin Says Could or would
Ron DeSantis pardon Donald Trump if Trump
goes to prison and DeSantis becomes president?
Could DeSantis pardon Trump to earn the political
favor of Trump supporters, and would he?
So there's two issues here.
And one of the issues is timing.
And let me explain what I mean by that.
DeSantis would want the the support of Trumpists
to become president if he runs, meaning he
needs the support before being president.
He could only pardon Trump once he is president.
So now, of course, he could announce while
running.
If you vote for me, I will pardon Trump.
If Trump were to be convicted of some crimes,
which I don't think is going to happen, so
it would be a campaign promise DeSantis could
make.
He couldn't actually do it until he were president.
But I actually see that the growing rift between
Trump and DeSantis will keep growing.
Trump has been attacking DeSantis of late.
DeSantis has come back and fired at Trump
a little bit and saying shouldn't have followed
him so much.
Early in the pandemic.
So I think that the hostilities between Trump
and DeSantis are much, much more likely to
continue growing, rather than the possibility
that DeSantis says, I will save the hero Trump.
Elect me to keep him safe.
I just don't see it.
We don't know if Trump's running in 2004.
We don't know if DeSantis is running in 24,
but that's my sense on a DeSantis Trump pardon.
Could he pardon him?
Yes.
Would he really do it?
I don't know that it really helps his strategy,
Amanda wrote in an.
Amanda said, Hey, David, I see in your videos
that you've needed to mention when information
on a video you're showing your audience are
lies and have been debunked.
I have no.
You would need to pause the video after each
lie to let us in your audience know it isn't
true.
And to remain in compliance with YouTube would
having a disclaimer on the bottom of the screen
be sufficient enough at the start?
Mentioning the content we're about to watch
is information that has been debunked and
is not true.
Play the video stop for your normal commentary
message on the bottom says this isn't true
or something like that.
I don't know.
I've noticed times taken away to stay in compliance.
Was wondering if there's any way around that?
Yeah, I don't think so.
You know, my understanding that we've gotten
from YouTube is you need to actually the content
needs to be when there is a misstatement,
you have to point out that it's a misstatement
and I know it gets a little clunky and we're
thinking about ways around it.
Remember, we're also on some platforms that
are audio only.
So having something visually on the bottom
of the screen that says these are lies you
are listening to wouldn't really help.
But I appreciate the sentiment and we're going
to keep working on it.
Amanda Camae wrote in and says, Do Democrats
want to lose David, sir?
I've been thinking about this for a while
now, but due to do the Democrats want to lose
elections?
I know the idea seems crazy, but when I think
about the people who were helped by the Republican
tax cuts, most of the House and Senate members
on both sides of the aisle would be at the
income level to profit off of what was done.
I do believe that on social issues, Democrats
do have strong feelings, but it seems like
they are still rich people with a lot to gain
from Republican policy.
Do they want to profit while also being able
to cast no votes?
They know in the end won't matter because
they're in the minority?
Crazy thought, but maybe there is some truth
in there.
So there's two things here.
Cammie, you're right that on some issues,
Democrats in power seem to have the same interest
as Republicans, but they don't hide that.
We know that there's lots of issues where
you actually just ask them their opinion,
and there's very little difference between
Democrats and Republicans.
And we've talked about actual interest in
enforcing antitrust, right?
I mean, there's a bunch of different issues
at the end of the day.
Democrats want Democrats benefit from being
in power and the prestige that comes with
it more than saving a couple of points off
of their taxes if the top tax rate is 37 instead
of 39.
So while you're mathematically correct that
many Democrats in power in the House and Senate
pay slightly lower taxes thanks to the Trump
tax cuts.
I don't think that those two points are enough
to make them say, we don't even want to be
in power to save those two percentage points.
I think they have much more to gain by being
in positions of power.
That's my instinct.
And of course, you know, you might disagree,
but that's all the evidence I've seen points
in that direction.
All right.
If you have something you want to ask me,
talk to me about, inquire about criticize
demand a correction for even.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com,
and maybe your email will be featured on next
week's mailbag.
Remember that the show doesn't have to end
now.
We do the bonus show every day for our members.
And you can sign up at
Unidentified: join Packman dot com.